not that long ago
i received an invitation to spend a few
days at the
historic home of james madison
james madison of course was the fourth
president of the united states the
father of the constitution the architect
of the bill of rights
and as a historian i was really excited
to go
to this historic site because i
understand and appreciate
the power of place now
madison called his estate montpelier
and montpelier is absolutely beautiful
is several
thousand acres of rolling hills
farmland and forest with absolutely
breathtaking views
of the blue ridge mountains but it's a
haunting beauty
because montpelier was also
a slave labor camp you see james madison
enslaved
more than 100 people over the course of
his lifetime
and he never freed a single soul not
even upon his death
the centerpiece of montpelier is
madison's mansion
now this is where james madison grew up
this is where he returned to
after his presidency this is where he
eventually died
and the centerpiece of madison's mansion
is his library
this room on the second floor where
madison conceived and conceptualized
the bill of rights when i visited for
the first time
the director of education christian
coats
cool white dude
took me almost immediately to the
library
and it was amazing being able to stand
in this place
where such an important moment in
american history
happened but then after a little while
there christian
actually took me downstairs to the
sellers
of the mansion now in the cellars of the
mansion
that's where the enslaved african
americans who managed the house
spent most of their time it's also where
they were installing a new
exhibition on slavery in america and
while we were there
christian instructed me to do something
i thought was a little bit strange
he told me to take my hand and place it
on the brick walls of the cellar
and to slide it along until i felt
these impressions or ridges in the face
of the brick
now look i was going to be staying on
site on this former slave plantation for
a couple days
so i wasn't trying to upset any white
people
when this was over i wanted to make sure
that i could get out
but as i'm actually sliding my hand
along
the cellar wall i couldn't help but
think about my daughters and my youngest
one in particular
who was only about two or three years
old at the time because every time she
hopped out of our car
she would take her hand and slide it
along the outside
which is absolutely disgusting and then
and then if i couldn't get to her in
time she would take her fingers and pop
him in the mouth which would drive me
absolutely crazy
so this is what i'm thinking about when
i'm supposed to be a historian
but then but then i actually do feel
these impressions in the brick i feel
these ridges
in the brick and it takes a second to
realize what they are
what they are are tiny hand prints
because all of the bricks at james
madison's
estate were made by the children
that he enslaved and that's when it hit
me
that the library in which
james madison conceives and
conceptualizes
the bill of rights rests on a foundation
of bricks
made by the children that he enslaved
and this is hard history
it's hard history because it's difficult
to imagine the kind of inhumanity
that leads one to enslave children to
make bricks for your comfort
and convenience it's hard history
because it's hard to talk about
the violence of slavery the beatings the
whippings the kidnappings
the forced family separations it's hard
history because it's hard to teach
white supremacy which is the ideology
that justified
slavery and so rather than confront
hard history we tend to
avoid it now sometimes
that means just making stuff up
i can't tell you how many times i've
heard people say that states rights was
the primary cause
of the civil war that would actually
come as a surprise to the people who
fought in the civil war
sometimes we try to rationalize
hard history when people visit
montpelier and by people in this
instance i mean white people
when they visit montpelier and learn
about madison enslaving people
they often ask but wasn't he a good
master
a good master there is no such thing
as a good master there is only worse and
worser
and sometimes we just pretend the past
didn't happen i can't tell you how many
times i've heard people say
it's hard to imagine slavery existing
outside of the plantation south
no it ain't slavery existed in every
american colony slavery existed in my
home state of new york
for 50 years after the american
revolution
so why do we do this why do we avoid
confronting
hard history literary performer and
educator reggie gibson
had the truth of it when he said that
our problem as americans
is we actually hate history
what we love is nostalgia
nostalgia we love stories about the past
that make us feel comfortable about the
present
but we can't keep doing this george
santiana the spanish writer and
philosopher said
that those who cannot remember the past
are condemned
to repeat it now as a historian i spend
a lot of time thinking about
this very statement and in a sense it
applies to us
in america but in a way it doesn't
because inherent in this statement is
the notion
that at some point we stop doing the
things
that have created inequality in the
first place
and the harsh reality is we haven't
consider the racial wealth gap
wealth is generated by accumulating
resources in one generation
and transferring them to subsequent
generations
median white household wealth
is 147 000
median black household wealth
is four thousand dollars how do you
explain
this growing gap hard history
my great great grandfather was born
enslaved in
jasper county georgia in the 1850s
while enslaved he was never allowed to
accumulate anything
and he was emancipated with nothing he
was never compensated
for the bricks that he made my
great grandfather was also born in
jasper county georgia
in the 1870s and he actually managed to
accumulate a fair bit of land
but in the 19 teens jim crow took that
land from him
and then jim crow took his life
my grandfather leonard jeffrey senior
was born in georgia but there was
nothing left for him there so he
actually grew up
in newark new jersey and he spent most
of his life
working as a custodian job
discrimination
segregated education and redlining kept
him from
ever breaking into the middle class
and so when he passed away in the early
1990s
he left to his two sons nothing more
than a life insurance policy that was
barely enough to cover
his funeral expenses
now my parents both social workers they
actually managed to purchase a home
in the crown heights section of brooklyn
new york in 1980
for 55 000
now crown heights at the time was an all
black neighborhood
and it was kind of rough my brother and
i often went to sleep by the mid-1980s
hearing gunshots but my
parents protected us and my parents
also held on to that home
for 40 years and they're still there
but something quintessentially american
happened
about 20 years ago about 20 years ago
they went to sleep one night in an
all-black neighborhood
and they woke up the next morning in an
all-white neighborhood
and as a result of gentrification not
only did all their neighbors
mysteriously disappear
but the value of their home
skyrocketed so that home that they
purchased for 55 000
at 29 interest by the way that home
is now worth 30 times
what they paid it for 30 times do the
math with me that's 55
000 times 30 carry the zeros that's a
lot of money
so that means as their single and soul
asset
when the time comes for them to pass
that asset on to my brother and i
that will be the first time in my
family's history
more than 150 years after the end of
slavery
that there will be a meaningful transfer
of wealth
in my family and it's not because
family members haven't saved haven't
worked hard
haven't valued education it's because
of hard history so when i think about
the past
my concern about not remembering it is
not that we will
repeat it if we don't remember it my
concern my fear
is that if we don't remember the past we
will continue it
we will continue to do the things that
created
inequality and injustice in the first
place
so what we must do is we must disrupt
the continuum of hard history
and we can do this by seeking
truth by confronting hard history
directly by magnifying hard history for
all
the world to see we can do this by
speaking truth teachers teaching hard
history
to their students to do anything else is
to commit
educational malpractice and parents have
to speak
truth to their children so that they
understand
where we have come from as a nation
and finally we must all act on
truth individually and collectively
publicly and privately in small ways
and in large ways we must do the things
that will bend the arc of the moral
universe
towards justice to do nothing is to be
complicit in inequality
history reminds us that we
as a nation stand on the shoulders of
political giants like james madison
but hard history reminds us
that we as a nation also stand
on the shoulders of enslaved
african-american children little black
boys
and little black girls who with their
bare hands
made the bricks that serve as the
foundation
for this nation and if we are serious
about creating a fair and just society
then we would do well to remember that
and we would do well to remember them
thank you